اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
ساعه اخباريه جديده من العربيه نستعرض
ونرصد معكم فيها ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
25 قتيلا حصيله التصعيد الاسرائيلي في غزه
وصافرات الانذار تدوي في المستوطنه قرب
القطاع
رغم استمرار الاشتباكات اطراف سودانيه
تؤكد التوصل الى اتفاق على وقف النار في
محادثات جده في اي لحظه
لاول مره منذ اندلاعها موسكو تقر بصعوبه
الحرب في اوكرانيا وتتهم حلف الناتو بلعب
دور مباشر في النزاع
افات الاخيره قبل السباق الرئاسي التركي
مرشح المعارضه يسعى لحشد الاحزاب الكرديه
في صفه
حياكم الله بعد ثمان ساعات فقط من الهدوء
الحذر دوت صفارات الانذار في مستوطنات
الغلاف الاسرائيلي بعد التصعيد في قطاع
غزه والغارات الاسرائيليه المستمره منذ
فجر الثلاثاء والتي اسفرت عن مقتل 25
فلسطينيا بينهم قاده من حركه الجهاد
وسرايا القدس وارتفاع المصابين الى 76
فلسطينيه الفصائل ردت باطلاق مئات
الصواريخ من القطاع اخرها اطلاق ست قذائف
هاون على المستوطنات بحسب اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي تصعيد تعثرت معه المساعي
المصريه المستمره لوقف اطلاق النار وحول
هذه المساعي افادت وسائل اعلام فلسطينيه
بان وفدا من حركه الجهاد توجه الى القاهره
قادمه من تركيا لبحث التهديه وتعثرت جهود
وقف النار سيما بعد اغتيال اسرائيل
للقياده القدس علي غالي المسؤول عن الوحده
الصاروخيه في عمليه مشتركه لجيش الدفاع
وجهاز الشابات جنوب غزه في غارات اسفرت عن
مقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين بينهم قيادي في
سرايا القدس الجناح المسلح لحركه الجهاد
ويبدو ان الامور مفتوحه على مزيد من
التصعيد سيما بعد تهديدات الاسرائيليه
باستمرار الهجوم على القطاع وهذا ما اكد
عليه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو في اخر تصريح له تزامنا مع
الغارات الاخيره بينما توعدت حركه الجهاد
بان الاغتيالات الاسرائيليه لن تمر مرور
الكرام وان جميع الخيارات مطروحه
[موسيقى]
ومن حدود قطاع غزه تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه لانك الغاسلان مرحبا بك معي في
هذه ان النشره سؤال عن
الاوضاع الامنيه في الحدود هناك ايضا يعني
الحديث عن رشقات جديده من الصواريخ من
قطاع غزه باتجاه اسرائيل كيف هي الامور
ميدانيا من حول الكيلان
اهلا بك صحيح فعليا بعد هدوء استمر لمده
ثمان ساعات منذ ساعه الثانيه في منتصف
الليل حتى الساعه الثامنه وعشرين دقيقه
صباح اليوم كان هناك هدوء تام في قطاع غزه
وايضا لم يتم اطلاق الصواريخ الى قطاع غزه
او الى مستوطنات الغلاف او حتى الى مناطق
اخرى في اسرائيل ولكن منذ صباح اليوم منذ
تحديدا ساعه تقريبا كان هناك ثلاثه رشقات
اطلقت من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه من قطاع
غزه نحو المستوطنات غلاف غزه هنا ايضا
يعني
السفارات الانذار كانت تدوي في مناطق هنا
مختلفه في المستوطنات ايضا الملاجئ ما
زالت مفتوحه لدى المستوطنين والاسرائيليين
ايضا تحدثنا عن 8,000 مستوطن ومستوطنه
خرجوا من مستوطناتهم او من منازلهم في
المستوطنات هنا في غلاف غزه وتوجهوا الى
مدن يعني قريبه او اكثر امانا حسب يتم
وصفها حتى الان هم يعني لم يعودوا الى
منازلهم والى المستوطنات هنا القريبه من
الحدود والملاجئ ايضا ما زالت مفتوحه في
الجبهه الشماليه تخوفا من تدخل ايضا
الجبهه الشماليه وتصعيد اكبر من محتمل حتى
اللحظه هناك يعني هدوء يعني حذر حسب ما
يتم وصفه ولكن ايضا نستطيع سماع الطائرات
المراقبه والتي يصفها الفلسطينيين بطائرات
او يسموها بطائرات الزنانه بسبب صوتها
العالي جدا وحتى اللحظه هذا هو المشهد هنا
من الحدود مع قطاع غزه القبه الحديديه هل
تعاملت مع هذه الرشقات الصاروخيه التي
يعني اطلقت للمره الثالثه وفي دفعتها
الثالثه باتجاه اسرائيل لانا
صحيح القبه الحديديه ايضا قامت باسقاط
معظم الصواريخ التي اطلقت من قطاع غزه لكن
حاليا الحديث الاهم هو يدور حول التهدئه
ممكن ان تكون ربما في اليوم او غدا ولكن
يعني قياده في الجناح السياسي لحركه حماس
ايضا توجه الى القاهره صباح اليوم
للحديث عن
لنا طيب يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال المباشر
بالزميله لنا كلغاثه على كل حال شكرا
جزيلا لها من حدود قطاع غزه على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
ولا سياره
احمد الله يعوض عليك
من ورا من ورا بسيطه من ورا من ورا ولا
اشي ولا اشي بسيطه بالنسبه
قال السفير الامريكي لدى اسرائيل انه
واشنطن تعمل على التوصل للتهدئه في اسرع
وقت قبل ذلك اعلن البيت الابيض ان مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي تحدث مع مستشار
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
بشان غزه واشارت الى ضروره استمرار الجهود
في المنطقه للتوصل لوقف اطلاق النار مشددا
على ضروره تهدئه التوتر ومنع اراقه المزيد
من الدماغ كما جدد سلف دعم الاداره
الامريكيه الحازم لامن اسرائيل وحقها في
الدفاع عن شعبها من الهجمات الصاروخيه
العشوائيه من جانبه ايضا اعرب المتحدث
باسم الامم المتحده
انطونيو ان الامين العام انطونيو قلق مما
يحدث ودعا الى وقف اطلاق النار
من غزه ينضموا الينا صحفي احمد حرب احمد
مرحبا بك معي قبل قليل لانك الغازي كانت
تتحدث عن حاله ربما من الهدوء تسود في
الحدود حدود غزه الوضع الان في غزه كيف
يمكن وصفه مع الحديث عن رشقات صاروخيه
جديده اطلقت من غزه باتجاه المستوطنات
نعم زميلي نايف
هناك استهداف بطائر من صارون
باتجاه منزل في منطقه بيت حانون شمالي
القطاع وهذا جاء بالتزامن ايضا مع استهداف
لارض زراعيه فارغه ايضا في نفس البلده في
بلده بيت حانون الشماليه القطاع بالتزامن
مع قصف مرصد للمقاومه او للفصائل
الفلسطينيه في رفح جنوب القطاع هذا
بالتالي كان مع اطلاق ست قذائف هاون رصدت
خلال الساعتين الماضيتين باتجاه
المستوطنات والبلدات الاسرائيليه المحاديه
للقطع ولكن ما هو ملحوظ بان هناك انحسار
في كثافه اطلاق الصواريخ منذ خمس ساعات
وايضا في كثافه الغارات الاسرائيليه نلاحظ
بان يعني هناك حاله من الهدوء الحذر
والتوتر لكن والتسعيد
الان يتحدث الاعلام الاسرائيلي بان هناك
تقديرات امنيه تتوقع ردا من حركه الجهاد
على مقتل مسؤول الوحده
الصاروخيه علي حسن غالي ما هي التداعيات
او الخيارات المفتوحه التي تحدثت عنها
حركه الجهاد بانها ستكون مطروحه للتعامل
مع ما حدث من تصعيد ما حدث من استهداف
ايضا لعلي حسن غالي يعني كل الخيرات
مفتوحه من القيام بعمليات على الحدود او
يعني زياده اطلاق الصواريخ بشكل مكثف اكثر
بوصولها الى مدايات اوسع تصل حيفا ويافا
وتل ابيب وايضا الى البلدات الاسرائيليه
المحاديه للقطاع هذه هي الخيارات
والاحتمالات المفتوحه امام حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي ومعها بقيه الفصائل الفلسطينيه
حتى بمعنى ان حماس يمكن ان تكون جزءا من
من هذا الرد سيد احمد لان الحديث ان حماسه
الان تنسق مع مصر لوقف التصعيد للتهدئه
لوقف اطلاق النار ايضا كذلك بعد ان خلقت
الهدنه التي تم الاعلان عنها منتصف
البارحه نعم يعني
منذ اللحظه الاولى لعمليه اطلاق الصهريخ
كانت من خلال الغرفه المشتركه للفصائل
الفلسطينيه او للفصائل المسلحه في القطاع
وهذه الغرفه تضم حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
وحماس وبقيه الفصائل المسلحه العامله في
القطاع وبالتالي يمكن القول بان جميع
الفصائل بما فيها حماس والجهاد هي جزء من
الرد على يعني عمليه الاغتيال التي حصلت
فجره الثلاثاء وان يعني حماس الان هي تجري
اتصالات مع مصر من اجل يعني تهدئه الاوضاع
والتنسيق والاتصالات مع الجهاد الاسلامي
قبل قليل كان هناك تصريح من حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي بان رئيس الدائره السياسيه محمد
الهندي وصل الى مصر اليوم من اجل التباحث
مع الجانب المصري فيما يتعلق بالتصعيد
الاسرائيلي والمجريات التهدئه خلال يعني
الساعات او الايام القادمه ولكن حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي مطلبا وهو وقف سياسه
الاغتيالات وهذا يعني المطلب ربما اسرائيل
لا توافق عليه يعني في البدايه ولكن يعني
نترك الامور
امس بان يعني الوقت الاغتيالات قد حان كما
قال يعني عندما غرد في تويتر بالتالي هنا
كيف يمكن ان تتعامل الفصائل الفلسطينيه ان
استمر التصعيد
بهكذا شكل باستهداف قيادات في هذه الفصائل
بالقصف المكثف ايضا حتى على قطاع غزه
واستهداف اهداف محدده داخل القطاع وحتى
ايضا في الاراضي المفتوحه التي يتم فيها
استهداف منصات اطلاق الصواريخ
يعني الفصال الفلسطينيه تقول بان القصف
الاسرائيلي سيقابل برد باطلاق مزيد من
الصواريخ التي تصل الى تل ابيب والى حيفا
ويافا وهذا كما تقول الفصل الفلسطينيه
وتقدر بانه سوف يشل الحياه في اسرائيل
وهذا لا يحتمله الجانب الاسرائيلي ان تكون
الحياه مشلوله الحياه العامه نحن نتحدث
اليوم ان البلدات الاسرائيليه المحاذيه
للقطاع مخلاه الى باتجاه الوسط
والجنوب والشمال في في اسرائيل حركه
الملاحه امس كانت معطله في مطار بن غريون
بسبب وصول الصواريخ الى تل ابيب الحياه في
اسرائيل شبه معطله بسبب يعني حاله الطوارئ
والوضع الخاص الذي اعلنه اعلن عنه وزير
الجيش الاسرائيلي ومازال قائما حتى هذه
اللحظه فبالتالي يعني الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وحركه الجهاد الاسلامي تلعب في اطار حرب
الاستنزاف مع
اسرائيل اشكرك جزيل الشكر من غزه انضم
الينا الصحفي احمد حرب شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
وعلى وقع الهجوم الاسرائيلي اغلقت المتاجر
في غزه ابوابها في انحاء القطاع بينما
تراجعت بشده حركه البيع والشراء في
الاسواق في ظل بقاء معظم اهالي غزه داخل
منازلهم
الشعب يتغذى في حصار 15 سنه ما بالك يجيك
تصحيح زي هيك ويسكر فوق الموت يزيد
بموتوا الميت بموتش مرتين مره واحده
ما فيش حد بيتحرك من بيته كله نايم اليوم
عشان الوضع اللي احنا خايفين منه الكل
خايف الكل ملتزم البيوت بستنى رحمه من رب
العالمين
وانت شايف سمعنا كل الدوارم مسكره كيف
بدها تطلع
[موسيقى]
تزامنا مع هجوم غازات تنفذ اسرائيل عمليات
اقتحام واعتقالات في الضفه الغربيه حيث
اصيب عدد من الفلسطينيين خلال مواجهات
واشتباكات مسلحه في مخيم نور شمس بطولكرم
بعد اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه المخيم
لتنفيذ عمليات اعتقال فيما توفي شاب
فلسطيني متاثرا بجراح اصيب بها الاربعاء
برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي في بلده قباطيه
جنوب جنين في الضفه الغربيه ليرتفع عدد
القتلى في البلده الى ثلاثه واقتحمت
القوات الاسرائيليه جنين بالاليات وقتلت
الشبان الثلاثه وسط اشتباكات وسماع دوي
انفجارات في البلده كما نفذت حمله
اعتقالات واسعه في الضفه الغربيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل ايضا
بعد اعتقاله السلطات الباكستانيه تواصل
حمله الاعتقالات في صفوف انصار عمران خان
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد فيما تستمر المحادثات
بين وفتي الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع في
جده بواسطه سعوديه امريكيه اكد الناطق
باسم العمليه السياسيه خالد عمر يوسف ان
تفاؤلا حذرا بات يلوح في الافق على الرغم
من الاشتباكات المستمره في العاصمه
الخرطوم مشيرا الى ان المباحثات في جده
باتت
تقترب من التوصل الى اتفاق وقف اطلاق نار
في اي لحظه كما اشار الى احتمال اتفاق
الجيش والدعم السريع على انهاء الازمه
والاقتتال الدائري في السودان الناطق باسم
العمليه السياسيه شدد على ان حل الازمه
التي تعيشها البلاد هو الخيار السلمي
من ام درمان ينضم الينا الصحفي مقداد حسن
مقداد مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره الحديث
كان عن
طائرات تحلق فوق سماء ام درمان الحديث
ايضا عن المحادثات هناك في جده وبان هناك
ما يلوح في الافق لاتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
هل الامور هادئه في ام درمان ام نزلت
الاشتباكات مستمره
نعم مدينه ام درمان
كاختلافها على اختلافها من غير المدن
الثلاثه هي كانت قد شهدت اشتباكات في
الايام الاولى اشتباكات عنيفه في الايام
الاولى اما بقيه الايام
فشهدت مناوشات هنا وهناك
وكذلك يعني تقدم لقوات الجيش السوداني في
بعض المناطق وانتشار قوات الدعم السريع في
مناطق اخرى في مدينه ام درمان سلاح
المدفعيه والمهندسين يستهدف ايضا في فترات
متباعده يستهدف اماكن تمركز قوات الدعم
السريع قوات الدعم السريع ما زالت متواجده
في محيط الهيئه العامه لدعوه التلفزيون
وجسر جنبات وكذلك في الشريط الذي يمكن ان
نقول وسط ام درمان وجزء من غربها قوات
الدعم السريه تتواجد لكن على اشتداد
المعارك مدينه ام درمان اقل عنفا من بق
المعارك في هذه اللحظات التي نتحدث فيها
هنالك طلعات جويه وغارات واستهداف لمقر
والدعم السريع
وتمركزاتها في مدينه بحري في هذه اللحظه
نحن نشاهد مدينه
هذه الاخبار
لاقل عنفا لتاكيدا لحديثك مصادر الجيش
السوداني تقول بان الطيران المدفعيه طردت
الدعم السريع من مناطق شرق الخرطوم بحري
تحدثت عن عمليه في الخرطوم بحري لطرد قوات
الدعم السريعه هكذا تحدث الجيش السوداني
ومصادر من داخل الجيش السوداني تحديدا ما
الذي يحدث هناك في الخرطوم بحري مقداد ان
كان لديك معلومات او تفاصيل اكثر
نعم مدينه بحري بالامس شهدت يعني اشتباكات
عنيفه جدا دارت المعارك فيها لساعات طويله
من الصباح ومن النهار كذلك وحتى ساعات
الاولى من الليل كانت المناوشات مستمره
فيها خصوصا في منطقه جسر الحلفايه
بالناحيه بناحيه مدينه بحري الان في هذه
اللحظات الطيران الجوي سلاح الجو السوداني
يحلق في سماء بحري بصوره مستمره منذ
ساعات وهنالك غارات جويه شهدناها قبل قليل
استهدفت
مواطن تمركز قوات الدعم السريع في في حي
الشمب وكذلك شمالا حتى حي الحلفايه
باعتبار ان قوات الدعم السريع لديها مقر
كثيره جدا وانتشارات واسعه في مدينه بحري
وهي مدينه كبيره جدا تمتد شرقا حتى شرق
النيل حيث جسر سوبا الذي يربط الخرطوم
والخرطوم قنديل بالعاصمه المثلثه وبالتالي
فان مدينه بحر هي المدينه التي شهدت يعني
اشتباكات عنيفه مقارنه مع مدينه ام درمان
ومقارنه كذلك مع وسط الخرطوم لكن وسط
الخرطوم تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات والغارات
الجويه التي تستهدف محيط القياده العامه
والقصر الجمله قبل ان اودعك مقداد مصادر
للعربيه الان تتحدث بان التوقيع على اتفاق
مبادئ اولي بين طرفي النزاع
بالسودان حول قبول الهدنه سيتم اذا مصادر
العربيه سيتم التوقيع على اتفاق مبادئ
اولي بين طرفي النزاع بالسودان حول قبول
الهدنه كل هذا الحديث يجري وسط مباحثات
سودانيه سودانيه في مدينه جده غرباء
السعوديه من ام درمان
انضم الينا الصحفي مقداد حسن شكرا جزيلا
لك
تعتري سكان العاصمه الخرطوم حاله من القلق
بشان الوضع الصحي الحليب حيث تتراكم
النفايات في الشوارع بسبب النزاع المسلح
وتواجه مركبات نقل النفايات صعوبات في
الوصول الى مواقع مختلفه داخل المدينه
بسبب نقص الوقود
عليكم السلام وموزعه
الاحياء اذا كان جوه او بره عشان الناس
فانا بالنسبه لي محتاجين لحاجتين لادوات
اوصل اوعيه
ازمه صحيه اخرى تهدد البلاد فالقتال
المستمر والنزوح تسببا بازمه وضغط على
مراكز الكلى التي تعاني اصلا من نقص
الادويه مراسل العربيه محمد عثمان زار احد
مراكز غسيل الكلى في مدينه بورتسودان في
ولايه البحر الاحمر
مشاهدينا انا الان في مركز بورسودان
لامراض وجراح حتى الكلى من المعروف ان
القطاع الصحي من القطاعات التي تاثرت بشكل
كبير جراء الحرب بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع سنقف على ما يجري داخل هذا المركز
على اعتبار انه يحتوي على 30 ماكينه غسيل
لمرضى الكلى ان كان هنالك واحد من المرضى
من الخرطوم
يعني لاحد كان بغسل في مركز فضيل والمركز
ومشينا على مركز في ابو ادم
والمركز برضه وقف قمت اتحركت على اساس من
بنات المنطقه اصلا
انت كم غسله في الاسبوع انا عندي غسلتين
في الاسبوع اربع ساعات اربع ساعات ولان
الامر عندي لا يرتبط بالمهنه فقط بقدر
ارتباطه بواقع انساني قد يتفاقم سريعا في
هذا المجال طلبنا من السلطات القائمه
التدخل وكانت الاستجابه سريعا بعد نصف
ساعه ودار هذا الحوار
تخص الولايه هنا يعني زي مشكله المويه
المركز مع الضغط الكبير بتاع العيانين
اضطرينا نفتح ورديات اضافيه بالتالي عندنا
اشكاليه في النوايا فمنحتاج منك انه توفر
لنا على الاقل تنكر في الاسبوع بوادي
عشرين طن ده يمكن الطلب
بالاضافه لانه بالتعاون مع وزاره الصحه
تساعدونه في غير غير المستهلكات الاساسيه
بتاعت الغسيل الحاجات المعينه للغسله ناس
الشايش والبطن والبلاصه المويه المحتاج لا
نحنا
التزام يعني ابتدام في الكل اسبوع مرتين
ملتزمين بها في كميه من الوافدين
للولايه وبالتالي الضغط على على المركز
كان كبير جدا جدا نحن ان شاء الله هنجيب
معاك في المزرعه دي وكله معيناتة أنت
تقريبا ان شاء الله مع الجهاز
هذه الولايه تعاني اشكالات كبيره جدا
تتعلق
بالمياه وبالتالي هذا يضع ضغط كبير جدا
على القطاع الصحي وبالتحديد على مراكز
غسيل الكلى هنا في هذه المدينه بورسودان
التي من المتوقع ان تستقبل اعداد كبيره
جدا من المرضى القادمين من الخرطوم محمد
عثمان لقناته العربيه والحدث من مدينه
بورسودان في ولايه البحر الاحمر الشرقيه
السودان
اعتقلت تسلطات الباكستانيه وزير الخارجيه
السابق شام محمود قريشي والذي كان يشغل
المنصب في حكومه عمران خان كما القت
السلطات الباكستانيه القبضه على زعيمين
بارزين اخرين في حزب عمران خان هما اسد
عمر وفؤاد شودري وذلك ضمن حمله لملاحقه
قاده حزب عمران خان الذي يواجه اتهامات
بالفساد كما نشرت الحكومه الجيش للمساعده
في السيطره على اضطرابات دمويه اشعلها
القبض على خان قبل ثلاثه ايام وقد مددت
محكمه باكستانيه الاربعاء اعتقال رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان ثمانيه ايام على
ذمه التحقيق في قضيه فساد
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال رئيس مجلس
القياده اليمني رشاد العليمي ان الشعب
اليمني يتطلع للحياه وليس للموت قائلا ان
الدعم السعودي يطال جميع المجالات
شعب اليمني يحتاج للسلام ويحتاج الى الصحه
ويحتاج الى الخدمات ويحتاج الى الطرقات
ويحتاج الى الحياه لا يحتاج الشعب اليمني
يتطلع للحياه ولا يتطلع الى الموت ان
الدلاله الرئيسيه لهذا التزامن مع السلام
هي رساله رساله ليست فقط الميليشيات
الحوثيه وانما ايضا لدعمها النظام
الايراني الدعم لها ان الشعب لان ان من
يدعمنا اليوم في تحالف العربي بقياده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه يدعمون
بالصحه ويدعمون بالطرقات ويدعمون بكل
المجالات
في سواء في المشاريع او في اللقاثه من
خلال المركز الملك سلمان وبالتالي انا
اعتقد هذه الرساله مهمه جدا في هذه اللحظه
يجب ان
يلتقطها الشعب اليمني اولا سواء في مناطق
المحرره او في المناطق الخاضعه الحوثيين
وهي رساله قويه ايضا الميليشيات الحوثيه
والادعمها
اننا نريد الحياه ونريد المزيد من
المشاريع والتنميه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل ايضا
واشنطن تحشد 24 الف عنصر امن على حدودها
تحسبا لتدفق مهاجرين
خمسه وعشرون قتيلا حصيله التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في غزه وسفارات الانذار تدويف
المستوطنات قرب القطاع
[موسيقى]
رغم استمرار الاشتباكات اطراف سودانيه
تؤكد التوصل الى اتفاق على وقف النار في
محادثات جدا في اي لحظه
لاول مره منذ اندلاعها موسكو تقر بصعوبه
الحرب في اوكرانيا تتهم حلف النيتو بلعب
دور مباشر في النزاع
في الاصطفافات الاخيره قبل السباق الرئاسي
التركي مرشح للمعارضه يسعى لحشد الاحزاب
الكرديه في صفه
حياكم الله من جديد فاعتراف نادر من
الكرملين حول الحرب في اوكرانيا اقر
المتحدث باسم الكرملين بان العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا صعبه للغايه
وانا تحقيق بعض الاهداف لم يكن امرا سهلا
وفي تصريحاته لمحطه تلفزيونيه بوسينيه قال
بيسكوب ان الغرب ارتكب اخطاء كثيره وخدع
روسيا مضطرنا لشن الحرب واتهم بسكوف حلف
الناتو بانه اصبح يلعب دورا مباشرا في
النزاع في اوكرانيا الى جانب كيف بعدما
كان في البدايه مشاركا غير مباشر متوعدا
بالرد على هجوم مسيرتين على الزمان
والمكان المناسبين واصفا الهجوم بانه عمل
ارهابي غير مقبول ومن موسكو تنضم الينا
مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعم كاتيا مرحبا بك
معي في هذه النشره كاتيا يعني نريد اجمال
لهذه التصريحات الروسيه الحديث عن صعوبه
الحرب في اوكرانيا ربما لاول مره ياتي هذا
الحديث لماذا هذا التوقيت
بالفعل كان اليوم تحدث
المتحدث باسم الكرملين عن صعوبه كبيره
تواجهها روسيا في العمليه العسكريه التي
تخوضها على اوكرانيا هو اكد ان هذه هي
عمليه عسكريه وليست حرب مره اخرى قال ان
روسيا تخوض عمليه عسكريه لانها اذا ارادت
ان تخوض الحرب لذلك سيؤدي ذلك الى تدمير
المدن بكاملها في اوكرانيا هي تريد فقط ان
تقوم بتحقيق اهدافها بنزع السلاح ولكنها
صعبه كما قال لان روسيا كانت قد بدات
نزاعها فقط مع اوكرانيا وبعد تدخل الناتو
كما قال اصبح الوضع اصعب واصبحت العمليه
العسكريه تجري ببطء شديد لذلك روسيا كما
قال على ان على الرغم من هذه الصعوبات
التي تواجهها على الارض ولكنها ستذهب الى
النهايه وتحقق جميع الاهداف التي وضعتها
ولكن هو عاد واكد ان هناك بعض الاهداف تم
تحقيقها في العام السابق هي ضم بعض
الاراضي خلال العام السابق من خلال
استفتاء قام به قامت به روسيا هناك ادت
الى ضم هذه الاراضي الى الاراضي الروسيه
واشار ايضا طبعا الى صعوبه الوضع الان في
باخمت وبعد التصريحات التي كنا نسمعها من
القوات الخاصه لفاغنر على الارض التي كانت
دائما تشير الى صعوبه الوضع هناك والتقدم
بسبب اولا نقص الزخائر وبسبب ثانيا وجود
مقاومه كبيره من الجانب الاوكراني ولكن
منذ صباح اليوم كان هناك تصريحات لبعض
المقاتلين قوات الخاصه لفاغنر بان هناك او
بقي بضع امتار
لسيطره الكامله من قبل القوات الخاصه
والقوات الروسيه على هذه المدينه التي
يجري القطار عليها منذ فتره طويله وكانت
روسيا دائما تسعى على هذه المدينه
بالاضافه الى
قواتابع طبعا ما يجري هناك ميدانيا ايضا
مع زميلنا رائد شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو
مراسله العربيه كاتيا على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل اذا جددت اوكرانيا
اطلاق صفارات الانذار في مقاطاعتي تشيرنيف
وسومي ذلك تحذيرا من ضربات جويه روسيه
متوقعه وافدت وسائل اعلام بان صافره
الانذار هذه هي الثانيه في تلك المناطق
خلال فتره قصيره كما يشن الجيش الروسي
ضربات صاروخيه وجويه على مواقع حيويه
اوكرانيا خصوصا عقب الهجوم الاوكراني على
القرم في الايام القليله الماضيه وفق
وكاله الروسيه
وبالتزامن شنه القوات الاوكرانيه هجوما
مضاده نجح في اجبار القوات الروسيه في
باخمت على التراجع وقال القائد العسكريه
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تراجعت
لمسافه تصل الى كيلو مترين في بعض مناطق
باخموت
من دونات سكان انضموا الينا مراسل العربيه
رائد الاغبر رائد مرحبا بك معي في هذه
النشره رائد حديث عن هجوم اوكراني مضاد
هذا الهجوم لاي مدى اجبر القوات الروسيه
على التراجع فعلا في وهل تراجعت فقط
كيلومترين
نهارك طيب نايف الهجمات الاوكرانيه
المضاده بالفعل هي
مستمره منذ عده ايام ولابد ان الذخيره
والدعم العسكري الذي وصل من الغرب لايدي
القوات الاوكرانيه لعب دورا كبيرا بهذه
الهجمات وانطلاقها لكن هذه الهجمات لم تكن
يعني مقصوره على باقي شملت مدينه افديف
كمدينه مارينكا اوغلادار مناطق عديده شنت
فيها القوات الاوكرانيه هجمات مضاده لكنها
كانت محدوده حيث كانت التصريحات الرسميه
والمعلومات من ارض المعارك ان القوات
الروسيه تمكنت من ايقاف هذه الهجمات ولم
تسمح للقوات الاوكرانيه التي كانت ترغب
بالعوده والسيطره على مناطق خسرتها سابقا
ودفع الجيش الروسي للانسحاب بخصوص مدينه
باخمت يعني
المصدر من المعارك فعلا هناك سيطره للقوات
الاو على عده احياء وعده مناطق ربما تكون
حسب المصدر من المناطق الغربيه لكن اليوم
ظهرت فيديوهات اظهرتها وكالات الانباء
الروسيه تؤكد ان قوات فاجنر وصلت الى اخر
المدينه والحديث عن اكثر من نصف كيلو متر
حسب التصريح الرسمي للمقاتلين من فاجنر
لاكمال السيطره على المدينه ربما تكون هذه
العوده للقوات الاوكرانيه في مناطق اطراف
المنطقه الغربيه وليس في العمق ربما يكون
التقدم لقوات فاجنر في نواحي والعوده
لقوات اوكرانيه من نواحي اخرى ما زالت
المعالق الضاريه ومحتدمه بالفعل في تلك
المنطقه الغربيه وهنا كر وفر او تقدم
وتاخر في هذه الايام يتقدم جيش الروسي
احيانا وينسحب احيانا حسب المصادر من ارض
المعركه هناك نايف لابد من التذكير بعجاله
ان اليوم يشهد او يصادف ذكرى الاستفتاء
الاول من اجل الانفصال عن اوكرانيا اليوم
حذرت السلطات من التجول والخروج الى
الشوارع ونصحت المواطنين بعدم الخروج من
اجل يعني تحسبا من اي قصف يمكن ان يصيب
قلب المدينه مع استمرار القصف الاوكراني
على اطراف المدينه واصابه عدد من
المواطنين على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
من دونتس العربيه رائد الاخبار
اتهمت كل من اذربيجان وارمينيا بعضهما
بالمسؤوليه عن تبادل اطلاق النار في منطقه
حدوديه بين البلدين ومن جهه عقاله وزاره
الدفاع الارمينيه ان قوات اذربيجان قصفت
مواقع قواتها على الحدود بالمدفعيه وقذائف
الهاون معا ما اسبر عن اصابه الجنديين
ارمينيين في مقاله وزاره الدفاع
الاذربيجانيه ان مواقعها تعرضت لاطلاق نار
في وقت سابق ما ادى الى اصابه جندي
في خضم الاصطفافات والتحالفات في تركيا
يبرز اسم تحالف العمل والحريه والذي يشكل
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي اللبنه
الاساسيه لهذا التحالف ونقطه القوه الاكبر
فيه لذلك سعى مرشح المعارضه الرئيسي كمال
الى كسب ودي هذا التحالف ونجح بالحصول على
دعمهم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه فقط اما في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه فكلا الطرفين
يتنافسان في صناديق الاقتراح
[موسيقى]
في الانتخابات البلديه الماضيه دعم حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي مرشحين معارضه في المدن
الكبرى كانقر واسطنبول فخسر مرشحون ائتلاف
حاكم هذه المدن لاول مره منذ عقدين دعم
الحزب ذي الغالبيه الكرديه كان حاسما هذه
المعادله لن تتغير في الانتخابات القادمه
من ناحيه الشكل لكنها تغيرت لجهه مضمونه
لم يستطع الحزب الذي يحظى بدعم في المناطق
الكرديه من الانضمام لتحالف الامه المعارض
لرفض حزب الخير القومي المتشدد وزعيمته
ميرال اكشنر التعامل العلني والمباشره مع
الحزب لان القوميين ينظرون اليه كمتداد
لحزب العمال الكردستاني لكن في المقابل لم
تمانع اكشنر من تواصل شريكها في تحالف
الامه كمال كلجدار اوغلو مع قاده الحزب
الكردي لكسب ودهم وضمان تاييدهم وفق هذه
المعادله بقيت العلاقه بين تحالف الامه
وحزب الشعوب قائمه لسنوات تعاون من تحت
الطاوله ودعم كردي لمرشحي التحالف لكن حزب
الشعوب الذي اراد اعترافا علنيا بدوره
وحقوق الاكراد من قبل تحالف الامه يدرك
تماما استحاله انضمامه لهذا التحالف لذلك
قرر التحالف العمل والحريه جاذبا اليه
احزابا يساريه صغيره
الاستبيانات والاحصاءات بالاضافه الى
الدورات الانتخابيه السابقه اظهرت بلا
ادنى شك بان الاصوات الكرديه المحسوبه على
حزب الشعب الديمقراطي هي عنصر توازن مهم
في الانتخابات وعليه ستبقى الاصوات
الكرديه عنصرا مهما وسيكون لها دور كبير
في تحديد مسار التصويت ينصب هدف هذا
التحالف مباشره على الانتخابات البرلمانيه
ودخول البرلمان باكبر عدد من النواب لكنه
فضل عدم طرح مرشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
ودعم مرشح تحالف الامه كمال كلجدار اوغلو
ضد اردوغان فكل التحالفين يريدان ازاحه
اردوغان عن المشهد
الكردي يمتاز بوعي سياسي عال يمكنه من
تحديد مصلحته في الانتخابات وحزبنا يثق
بوعي الناخب الكردي الذي سيتجه نحو
التصويت لصالح المرشح الذي يختاره الحزب
ساعه الجدار اوغلو بقوه للحصول على دعم
هذا التحالف عبر تقديمه وعودا قاطعه
بمناقشه القضيه الكرديه في البرلمان لكن
مدى استجابه الاكراد لدعوه التحالف
بالتصويت لزعيم المعارضه لا يبدو واضحا
حتى اللحظه فحسابات الانتخابات البلديه
لدى الناخب تختلف تماما عن حساباته في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
الينا محلله السياسيه جواد مرحبا بك معي
في هذه الساعه اريد ان ابدا السؤال بما
ختم به زميلنا قبل قليل زيدان زين كلو في
هذا التقرير كيف تختلف حسابات الناخب بين
الحسابات البرلمانيه والرئاسيه وهل يمكن
ان يكون هذا الاختلاف موجودا في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه القادمه
تحيه لكذا لمشاهدينا الكرام بدايه قبل بدء
حمله الانتخابات وقبل ان
يشخص هنا مرشحين من الاحزاب المعارضه
كان هناك خلاف بين المعارضه انه هل يكون
مرشح المعارضه من القوميين الاتراك او من
شخص معتدل بين الجانبين الكردي والتركي
وغير ذلك يعني بصراحه كان المنافسه في
الاعلام بين منصوريه رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
من القوميين السابقين الاتراك بين كمال
كوليستر اصله كردي ما من حزب الشعب
الجمهوري اليساري كما الكوليستر اوغلو
عندما قدم ترشحه
للمعارضه
الاكراد وحزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه كانوا
راضين جدا عن هذا الاداء بخلاف القوميين
وبصراحه دعم حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه
الكرديه واضح جدا لكم اشترى اوغلو قبل هذا
الانتخابات كان اصوات لصالح حزب الشعب
الجمهوري وكما الكوليسترو كان واحد بالمئه
او اثنين بالمئه في المدن الشرقيه من قبل
الاكراد لكن مع وجود دعم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي الان سبعين بالمئه وثمانين
بالمئه من المواطنين في المدن الشرقيه سوف
اعلنوا سوف يصرف لصالح كمال مع اكراد
الموجودين في مدن مثل اسطنبول وانقرض ما
هي حدود المعارضه اليوم سيد جواد في هذه
الانتخابات هل هي حظوظ مرتفعه امام رجب
طيب اردوغان ام ان
اردوغان يملك شعبيه ربما اعلى وكذلك ايضا
السنوات في الرئاسه الماضيه والكثير ايضا
من الازمات التي استطاعت خطيها او حتى
التي اخفق فيها يمكن ان تؤثر كذلك في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه تحدث هنا عن
ارضيه الناخبين
طبعا شعبيه الرئيس اردوغان لا زالت موجوده
يعني لا ننكر ذلك ابدا لكن كان هناك عده
اسباب لتراجع شعبيته اولا تضخم الاسعار
وملف الاقتصادي الفاشل بصراحه هو اذا يفوز
في هذه المره من الانتخابات سوف نشاهد
ازمه اقتصاديه قويه في تركيا لانه لا يوجد
عندهم برنامج جديد طاقه جديده ليقدموا
للشعب التركي
بالمقابل قضيه الزلزال ايضا كان تراجع
شعبيته ايضا جيل جديد خمسه سته ملايين من
الشباب لاول مره سوف يصوت لصالح المعارضه
او الحكومه اكثريتهم مع المعارضه والدعم
الاكراد وفي هذه المره اولا بصراحه رئيس
اردوغان وحزبه لا يقدر ان يصل الى
51% هذا من المؤكد مؤكد جدا
الارشيف لا يكذب
يسجلون هذه الكلمات سوف نقيمه يوم الاحد
بالليل بعد الانتخابات بساعات لكن
المعارضه في هذه المره قويه جدا جدا تختلف
القضيه من الانتخابات السابقه اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من اسطنبول السياسي
وهذه صور من التجمعات الانتخابيه لاردوغان
وكريتشدار اوغلو في تركيا
التعديلات الاخيره مشاهدينا على قانون
الانتخابات التركيه سيكون لها تاثير مباشر
على كيفيه تشكيل البرلمان الجديد كما
ستغير من استراتيجيه الاحزاب للفوز
بالمقاعد المزيد من التفاصيل مع الزميل
روان حمزه
المشهد الانتخابي المتعلق بالبرلمان
التركي في انتخابات 2023 بتركيا مسار
مختلف عن سابقيه خاصه فيما يتعلق بتاثير
التعديلات في قانون الانتخابات التي اقرها
البرلمان في ابريل الماضي ودخلت حيز
التنفيذ في مارس الماضي تلك التعديلات
وخفضت الحد الادنى المطلوب من الاصوات
لدخول الحزب السياسي للبرلمان الى سبعه في
المئه بدلا من عشره في المئه حيث تمنع
العتبه الانتخابيه اي حزب يحصل على اقل من
سبعه في المئه على مستوى البلاد من شغل
مقعد في البرلمان حتى لو جاء اولا في
دائره انتخابيه معينه يا نص التعديل
الانتخابي ايضا على ضروره ان يكون الحزب
السياسي الراغب في المشاركه بالانتخابات
قد عقد لمرتين متتاليتين مؤتمرته الكبرى
في الولايات والاقضيه فيما يتضمن القرار
تعديلا بمنع انتقال النواب من حزب الى اخر
من اجل تسهيلات الدخول في الانتخابات
في انتخابات عام 2018 انتقل 15 نائبا من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري الى حزب الخير لتمكينه
من دخول الانتخابات حيث كان قانون
الانتخابات يشترط تشكيل كتله نيابيه للحزب
داخل البرلمان مؤلفه من 20 نائبا ليتاح له
خوض الانتخابات المقبله وبالتعديل الجديد
لن يكون ذلك متاحا في القانون السابق كانت
الاحزاب المتحالفه تتمكن من تجاوز العتبه
الانتخابيه في عموم تركيا من خلال التحالف
لكن في التعديل الاخير يتم الحصول على
مقاعد برلمانيه عن طريق اصواتهم
الانتخابيه اي انهم لن يستفيدوا من
الاصوات الزائده وبالتالي فانه لن يتم
تمثيل الاحزاب في البرلمان عبر الاصوات
الفائضه
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا حشدت الولايات المتحده
الاربعاء 24 الف عنصر امن استعدادا للرفع
الوشيك لاجراء صحي كان معمولا به منذ
بدايه جائحه كورونا وساعد في ترحيل
مهاجرين عابرين برا نحو اراضيها اقل وزير
الامن الداخليه الامريكي لخانترو مايروكاس
ان الايام المقبله قد تكون صعبه بعد رصد
عدد كبير من المهاجرين الوافدين الى
الحدود
المثير للجدل ينتهي الخميس
قانون تايتل 42 سمح للسلطات الامريكيه
برفض المهاجرين المكسيكيين وذلك بحجه نقل
وباء كورونا للولايات المتحده عشيه انتهاء
القانون تكدس الالاف من المهاجرين على
الجانب المكسيكي من الحدود ما دفع
الولايات المتحده لنشر اربعه وعشرين الف
عنصر امن على حدودها ومن المتوقع ان يستمر
الامر كذلك لاسابيع
اعلنت كوريا الجنوبيه تخفيض مستوى
الاجراءات المتخذه لمكافحه فيروس كورونا
بدءا من يونيو المقبل وقلت الحكومه ان
الفرق المتخصصه لن تطالب المصابين بالحجر
الصحي لمده سبعه ايام على ان تواصل
السلطات الصحيه التوصيه بخمسه ايام من
العزل الذاتي للمصابين لكنه لن يكون
اجباريا كما سيتم ايضا اسقاط متطلبات
ارتداء الاقنعه في جميع المرافق الطبيه
والصيدليه
قبل ختام تذكيرهم بابرز العناوين
25 قتيلا حصيله التصعيد الاسرائيلي في غزه
وسفارات الانذار تدوي في المستوطنات قرب
القطاع
رغم استمرار الاشتباكات اطراف سودانيه
تؤكد التوصل الى اتفاق على وقف النار في
محادثات جده في اي لحظه لاول مره منذ
دلاعها موسكو تقر بصعوبه الحرب في
اوكرانيا تتهم حلف الناتو بلعب دور مباشر
في النزاع
في الاصطفافات الاخيره قبل السباق
الرئاسيه تركي مرشح المعارضه يسعى لحشد
الاحزاب الكرديه في صفة
شكرا لكم المتابعه
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات